i'll step over here and i'll hit the
background why don't you step over here
so you can read the background
[Music]
i'm sorry i'm bringing a cheat sheet
this is like uh dude i just read it my
entire act out of a book
[Music]
it was a first date my mom set up
it was uncomfortable
i remember she told me
in her past life that she was a
cat and not only that
she has three extra toes she lets her
back hair grow
she has five little
[Music]
but guess what i'm gonna need weed
[Music]
let me ask you guys an honest question
can you hear the lyrics or does that
need to go down to check
all right good all right good sounding
[ __ ] great it sounds great you're a
good guitar yeah i know what you're
doing
you're moving back home yeah but your
parents don't know
they think you have a job
[Music]
on the floor
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when you have to go to her cousins
[Applause]
[Music]
guess what
[Music]
you're gonna need
your reason be it
is enough for me guess what
you're gonna wait
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
[Music]
you